-Thank you for being here.
-How cool. Oh, my gosh.
-Feels great, right?
Come on, yeah. They love you.
I want to thank you
for being here,
but I will say how cool it was
to meet your sister,
by the way, backstage.
-Sister's here, yeah.
-Caroline?
-Caroline.
It was just her birthday.
-It was?
Happy birthday, Caroline.
Should have said it backstage.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But that was a cool story that
you told me back there.
I guess when you were about to
start acting,
she encouraged you,
and she said...?
-Yeah, I was probably, like,
a freshman in high school,
and she was a part of, like,
stage crew.
You know, sound and lights.
-Yeah.
-And I was gonna
sleep in and skip
and just miss
the stage crew thing,
but she was like,
"Come on, get up," you know,
and sort of brought me along.
And you know, yeah.
-Got you into the theater.
-Got me into it, yeah.
-And thank goodness
you stuck with it.
-I did.
-Did she say, "If you do this,
and you get on 'Fallon'..."
-Exactly.
-"I gotta be there."
-I gotta be there.
-And she's here.
-And she's here tonight.
-So it's all happening.
This is all supposed to happen.
-Yes.
-Caroline, we thank you.
-Thank you, Caroline.
-Steve Harrington, this is
your first big break.
-For sure, yeah.
-Where were you working
before then?
-I was a waiter.
-Good.
-Waiter.
-You have to.
-Have to, yeah, waiting tables
and doing commercials.
-How were you as a waiter?
-I was a pretty good waiter,
I think.
-Really?
-I was a great waiter.
I was pretty, uh, charismatic.
-Okay, I like that.
-And what I lacked in
organization,
I made up for in maybe,
delivery, I guess I would say.
-Yeah, and you just got
the audition,
and you were like,
were you working when
you found out?
-I was, so I auditioned for,
you know,
they did the big cattle call
or whatever.
You know how it works, they
send out across the country.
Taped it, didn't hear anything.
Moved on.
3 months later, got a callback
for some different role,
for Steve, and I was like, "Oh,
man, the jerky boyfriend?
Okay, whatever."
And sent that in, yeah.
-That's hilarious.
The jerky boyfriend, yeah.
-The jerky boyfriend.
It was what he was.
It was like, you know, James
Spader in "Pretty in Pink."
Something like that.
-Yeah.
-And so my friend,
Matt Williams,
he would kind of help me
tape all my auditions.
And we just, you know,
set up the camera.
Got, like, two mugs,
pretty DIY,
and did the tape, and then
he worked at
the restaurant with me,
and so when they did call
and I ended up getting
the job and stuff,
there was a nice moment of,
like, a silent...
He was a food runner
and I was a waiter,
and I got the call in the back,
and was like, "Oh, my God.
This is great. I don't have to
work at a restaurant anymore!"
[ Laughter ]
And I saw him.
He was probably stocking
the truffle aioli or something.
An I just gave him, like, a,
"I got the job!"
-Yeah! And he was like,
"What's up, buddy?"
-He was like, "Yeah!
Get back to work, though!"
-Get back to work, yeah.
"We'll celebrate after."
-"Is this for 9?
Are you table 9, right?"
-You didn't think you were gonna
make it past Season 1?
-Yeah, the brothers wrote,
you know --
I read one, maybe, episode
of the show, two episodes,
and it was kind of like,
we read three episodes
and then they had
two more and stuff.
So it was really, they were
building it as they were going.
-It was day-to-day for you.
-It was day-to-day.
-I can't imagine
the show without you.
-That's very nice of you to say.
-You are "Stranger Things."
We need you. We need Steve.
[ Cheering ]
-Thank you.
-You make the whole show.
I love you.
-Thank you.
I will tell the brothers
that you said that.
-Yeah, please.
They made me nervous.
Because, you know,
before this season,
Netflix put out a billboard,
I don't know if saw this but...
-Yeah, I did see this.
-Look at this.
This is on the billboard.
It says "Protect Steve."
-Yeah.
So I actually paid for this.
It was really expensive.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-It was.
-Oh, that's a lot of money.
-I pretty much broke even.
It was worth it.
-It was totally worth it.
-Yeah.
-But you obviously --
we can say this.
We're allowed to say it,
because...
-I'll let you say it.
-I'll do it.
Noah came on the show
and said, someone dies.
-Yeah.
-It's not you.
-It's not me.
-Okay. There you go.
We can say that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you tough with the spoilers
and holding in the secrets
and all that stuff?
-Um...
-Like your family wanted...?
-Not super.
-Does Caroline know?
-Yeah, she knows.
Well, she doesn't --
She gets very scared.
A lot of my family doesn't like
scary stuff, unfortunately.
-Especially if it's to do
with their family member.
Yeah, exactly.
-Joe? You can't, yeah.
-You know, they'll watch some,
but mostly kind of through...
It's pretty scary.
-It's a global phenomenon.
Congratulations.
It's the biggest thing.
And you just got nominated
for, like, 13 Emmy Awards.
-Those brothers,
it's like their life.
They deserve it.
They're the best.
-The Duffer Brothers are great.
-They're the best guys.
-They are, right?
And creative and fun.
But when did you realize,
like, that it is global?
It's, like, bigger than just...
It's bigger than Chicago.
It's big in America.
It's bigger than.
-We did some press.
My other sister, Lizzie,
came with me,
and we went and did
some press in in Italy,
which was my --
I had gone
in high school as a trip.
Pretty cool high school trip,
actually.
To go to Italy.
I mean, that's pretty cool.
-Wow.
-That's a story
for another day.
But we went for the press,
and we were kind of
walking down the street
and there was just --
we were walking,
and this little Italian girl,
saw me, clocked me.
I could tell.
And then I heard her go,
[ Italian accent ]
"Stranger Things!"
From behind. I was like...
-Wow.
-Oh, my gosh.
-In a different accent.
To hear "Stranger Things."
[ Italian accent ]
"Stranger Things!"
-"Lizzie, let's go!"
-Wow.
This is actually becoming giant.
-Exactly, yeah, you kind of...
You know, it feels like
such a small thing when you're
doing it down there, when
you're shooting and working.
-And then to see
the final product.
-So many people have seen it.
It's crazy.
-I feel like you're also --
I've seen you perform,
as well, live as a musician.
-Oh.
-So you must feed off...
-Do like doing it,
feeding off the audience?
-I mean yeah. Like, I come
from doing high school theater.
I mean, that's what I...
-That's a good energy.
-It's a good energy.
It's all about that live thing.
So when I lived in Chicago,
that was kind of my --
I didn't do any theater there.
The name of your band,
just because
I think I'm saying it right.
-Yeah.
-It's "Joe." Is that correct?
-Correct. It's very confusing.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
So then you walk in the room,
you go, "I'm here to see Joe."
Well, that's interesting,
because it's spelled...
-D-J-O.
-Yeah.
-"Joe."
-It's really funny.
-There's not really
a story behind it.
I had a bunch --
-Like DiGiorno?
-Like DiGiorno, pretty much.
-Yeah.
-So, not delivery, is Djo.
-Exactly.
-Yeah, exactly.
-It's Djorno.
-But why "Djo"? Any reason?
-Nah, I just thought --
I wanted to put it out
with, it's connected to me,
but it's not, you know,
directly connected to me,
was the idea.
-Does it confuse people?
-It confuses people
all the time.
People say D-joe, DiGiornio.
All sorts of different --
-DJ Oh! Yeah, yeah.
-DJ OH!
[ Imitates record scratch ]
-"I'm not a DJ. I'm a band."
-No, no, no, no, no.
-But you have
a new record coming out.
-Yep, yep.
-September?
-Yep, September 16th.
And, you know, fun.
-Do you know the title?
Can we say it?
-We can. It's called "Decide."
-Yeah.
No way. So that's out September.
"Decide"?
-Decide, yeah.
-"Decide" comes out
September 16th.
-"D'just Decide," probably.
-Yeah.
You always add a "D'".
You can always add that in post.
-Exactly.
-You can always add that later.
But you're playing big gigs.
You're playing Lollapalooza?
-Man. Yeah.
I'm going to be
definitely nervous.
Are you excited?
-It's fun!
I get to wear this wig.
I wear a wig and get to
dress up the whole band.
It's kind of like a Devo
sort of thing.
Everyone dresses up.
-No.
-Yeah.
-You do that?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
-And do people...
Because then
you can walk around
and go in the crowd
and not be noticed?
-Well, that was the idea.
I released it with
this different name.
I was kind of like, you know,
inspired by Andy Kaufman,
you know?
-Of course.
-So that was kind of the idea.
Kind of this alter ego.
-I think it's great.
You're fantastic.
And I think you could do it.
You could do both
for a long time.
-That's the idea.
Just keep doing that.
And that'll kind of be fueled
by, you know, acting stuff.
-Keep crushing it, buddy.
-Thank you.
I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here is a joke here in
Season 4 of Volume 2
of "Stranger Things."
Take a look at this.
-I'm not sure I love the idea
of you driving.
-I'm just starting the sucker.
Harrington's got it.
Don't you, big boy?
[ Electricity crackles ]
-What the hell? Hey!
Open this door!
-Hey!
-Unlock the doors!
-[Bleep]. [Bleep].
-Everybody hang onto something!
-Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
Let's go, let's go!
-Drive, Steve, drive!
-Go, go, go!
[ Screaming ]
-[Bleep].
-Go, go, go!
-[Bleep]! They look pissed.
-I mean, it's not
every day you lose
your house and car
in one fell swoop.
-Hold on, hold on!
♪♪
-Oh, my God.
-That's how you do it
right there!
Joe Keery, everybody!
Season 4 of "Stranger Things"
is streaming now on Netflix.
"Decide" comes out
September 16th.